this is live from Korea lights I'm Julie
Englander over five million Americans
are living with traumatic brain injury
and more live sustained traumatic brain
injury every day in motor vehicle
accidents viruses crime sports and other
activities but traumatic brain injuries
or TBI s come in many different forms
and treatments and healthcare for TBI
patients are as far ranging in his new
book head cases stories of brain injury
and it's aftermath Michael Paul Benson
is an expert explores the harsh
realities and toward by brain injury
survivors Neeson is a traumatic brain
injury case manager brain injury
survivors go to him after they've
exhausted every options of Kirkus
Reviews his mission is getting help for
people stuck in the purgatory of the US
healthcare system his job which takes
him across the country is convincing
hospital administrators and neurologists
and specialty care centers to give
clients suffering debilitating brain
injuries a new chance at life intriguing
case histories related with a personal
passion that sets Mason's book apart
from Oliver Sacks
cooler writings on the subject says
Kirkus Reviews Michael Paul Mason worked
as a brain injury case manager for the
neurologic Rehabilitation Institute at
Brookhaven Hospital and he has spoken
about brain injuries on CBS's
up-to-the-minute NPR's Morning Edition
Leonard low-paid show and PBS new hour
with Jim Lehrer
he is currently a contributing writer to
Discover Magazine and when Mason's
article dead men walking was published
in February 2007 it ignited a national
debate about the treatment of brain
injured soldiers Mason has since
traveled to Iraq to report on health
care and humanitarian issues please
welcome Michael and Paul Mason - live
from Prairie light eye Julie thank you
thank you so much for having me thank
you for being on the program Michael
Paul Mason we're glad you're here I'd
like to first start with a more personal
view of what's going on in your life
that led you on the path as a caretaker
for people with traumatic brain injuries
sure well basically had been a freelance
writer in Tulsa for a number of years
and became fairly disillusioned with
with doing the kind of writing that I
was doing at the time which is mainly
copywriting
so I began exploring different options
and I wanted to go into a field in which
I could continue writing but I wanted to
be able to write about whatever work I
would be doing mental health was a very
alluring and interesting area for me so
I began to work an entry-level job as a
psych tech at a at a nearby hospital
from there I found a job opening at
Brookhaven hospital and what they were
looking for was someone who felt
comfortable in hospitals particularly
Psych hospitals someone who could you
know translates and review medical
records and at the same time be able to
communicate those letters via you know
written reports on behalf of brain
injured patients and so you know I met
with the people of Brookhaven and it was
a good foot and you know that's kind of
what got me into the end to the field
and you joined the staff there you
worked there for about five years
oh yeah a little over four years or
years okay what inspired you to write
the book headcases
well the further I became involved in
the lives of brain injury survivors the
more compelling their stories became to
me because I you know as I began to do
these evaluations all over the United
States I began to notice very similar
themes which is the life was going along
just fine and then something drastic
happened and you know life completely
London and in totally opposite direction
and you know there are 12 cases in the
in the book so give us a sense of about
them but other people because bring
traumatic brain injury rages I mean
there's so many different forms of it
yeah well you know and that's a
testament to just how complex the brain
is there
I've yet to exhausted the number of ways
a brand can be injured but in the book I
chose people that I thought exemplified
the more typical kinds of injuries even
though they seem very atypical in the
book the first chapter is about a
snowboarder who after a miscalculation
on the slopes develops a terrible
seizure disorder 120 seizures month
cheyanne Emmerich is his name and so he
goes from being a very popular athlete
to a reclusive playwright in Hollywood
you know it seems as though it's a huge
personality change but really it's a de
man grappling with you know his newfound
identity as a person with epilepsy
following that there's an account of a
woman who has a collision with a train
and when she emerges from her coma she
no longer has any memory to speak of I
mean she has some functional bits of
memory
she doesn't remember the daughter who
perished in the train wreck and she
doesn't remember any of her marriage
all fifteen or sixteen years of it so
memory problems are very typical of
brain injury survivors but this
particular cases is quite drastic there
is a story of a young Russian woman who
experiences a bicycle injury and she
goes on to become a very successful
photographer as well as a mathematician
and she's out in LA
a another woman Melissa felt oh who you
know is this sort of a type-a executive
following her brain injury she becomes
very interested in spiritual issues and
then of course I had to write about the
Iraq war and the brain injuries coming
from there but I would you know I'd be
remiss if I didn't also acknowledge the
Iraqis who were also injured in that war
as well you also wrote an article about
the Iraq war I think I mentioned that in
the beginning about dead men walking
with Quran and that started of ignited a
lots of debate about that about the
injuries taking place and therefore
let's hear your selection that you're
going to read from head cases and then
we'll get back to you and talk more with
you about the other cases in this book
and give the audience here a chance to
ask questions as well
okay so Michael Paul Masson head cases
is his book stories of brain injury in
its aftermath okay the the first excerpt
I'd like to read for you guys is a story
that's very meaningful to me because it
reveals kind of the the creation of the
book and how the book got started and
basically what happened was is that I
was having a meal I believe it was with
Julie fiddler Dixon who runs a rehab
called on with life and she said you
know you really should write about brain
injury and I said no I'm not not quite
sure I could I could do it just
something it's just such a complicated
area and you know III just didn't quite
feel right about and she said I know I
think I think he should and so I
eventually she she suggested that I take
a closer look at Kathy hearing story
Kathy herring is here than in the front
row and and I and I knew at that moment
that I would have to write about the
story if she would permit me to and she
did
and so so that chapter Robb Reb cannot
cries actually third the third chapter
in the book but it's actually the first
one that I wrote and it's the one that
convinced my editor that this is a story
that needed to be told on a national
scale so this is a this is Rob rabe
cannot cry Rob rabe cannot cry his 45
year old face is boyishly handsome and
expressive enough but he cannot cry he
can smirk and smile and grimace and
furrow his brow but he cannot cry oh he
can cry
his mother Cathy / Tufts a mother knows
I can't says Ron shrugging his shoulders
despite the volumes that comprise Rob's
medical records his inability to cry
isn't even afforded the dignity of a
diagnosis in fact it has been even
mentioned Rob raved cannot cry not like
the rest of us he cannot cry and it is
the lost detail to his army of doctors
and surgeons and therapists and nurses
Rob cuts an impressive figure from the
confines of a mechanized wheelchair he
maintains a stature giving you the sense
that he is towering alongside you even
though he is seated he welcomed me into
a conference room offered me a lunch of
Chinese takeout and asked how my trip to
Colorado had been and if I'd had any
trouble finding his business I did have
trouble I told him but your secretary
started me on what she does that to me -
he joked all the time that week I happen
to be attending a conference in Denver
and when I found an open slot to visit
Rob center in Greeley I jumped at the
opportunity
I'd heard Rob's name mentioned several
times in the past and I knew that he was
now running a rehab that featured some
sort of brain injury program
but I'd never had the chance to meet him
in person I also had an ulterior motive
I wanted to check in on Rob's mother and
visit her as well Kathy Haring Rob's
mother is widely regarded as the
matriarch of brain injury advocacy in
Iowa which is no small accolade since
Iowa has a reputation as one of the most
progressive and survivor friendly States
more options exist for Iowans with brain
injuries than exist for most other
Americans and Iowans have Kathy herring
and a handful of others to thank when I
first met Kathy several years ago she
was a vivacious spirited woman who was
bustling among a crowd of health
professionals during a brain injury
seminar sponsored by her rehabilitation
center on with life
located in Ankeny Iowa although it was
the first time we had met she greeted me
with open arms and explained that she
knew about me in the hospital I worked
for and that I was a welcome guest she's
the kind of woman who's a warmth and
openness can instantly put a person at
ease but there's also a side to Kathy
Haring that she doesn't often show a
side tempered through old testament
trials and tribulations the first half
of the year had not been kind to Kathy
during Iowa's annual Brain Injury
Association conference the president
Julie fiddler Dixon announced that Kathy
had been diagnosed with non-small lung
cancer and that she wasn't able to
attend due to complications resulting
from her illness later Julie pulled me
aside and explained in hushed tones the
Kathy wasn't doing well at all that the
cancer seemed malignant and that it may
have spread to her lymphatic system
already a few months later I spoke with
Kathy on the phone and my heart sank at
the sound of her voice gone was the
tenacity and its place I could make out
only a quiet resolve and acceptance
she was on strong she was on a strong
regime of painkillers and struggled to
put sentences together and she
complained that she had never known what
it was really like to be sick until she
had undergone chemotherapy although
everyone hoped for the best
she told me that she wasn't sure what
the next batch of test results would
show but either way I'm going to go see
Robin Colorado soon and she told me it's
going to be wonderful
I know rob was probably too popular and
handsome and promising at least that's
what an old college pal of mine would
say about him
so-and-so is too good for this world my
friend sent us something always happens
to the good ones and something did
happen to rob some say was terrible
others that it was part of a divine plan
but even fatalism and fate come up short
in explaining brain injuries there
aren't any good explanations there never
are in 1980
Ankeny was one of Des Moines lesser
satellites the tiny suburb hovering just
north of downtown it was small and rural
but it held enough lure to Kathy herring
and her new husband Fran she was done
with Indianola and the New Starts seemed
just right for the hearings Kathy
brought her son Rob along with her even
though she knew he probably wouldn't be
staying around for much longer
he had already graduated from high
school and had his eyes set on college
and girls and little else in high school
Rob had been a jog not a dumb jock or an
aloof jock but an entirely approachable
jock the kind of guy that made friends
just as easily as pocketing a pigskin
into a running backs hands he was a
quarterback he was a point guard he was
the star at six feet even and a lean
hundred and eighty pounds Rob felt he
was physically unstoppable and had the
record to back it up
no wonder then that Rob had no idea what
to do in the anticlimactic aftermath of
graduation stocking soup cans on a shelf
could only buy em so much
time so as soon as he settled into his
mother's house and made peace with his
new stepfather Rob enrolled in a nearby
Community College and started picking
away at his general ed classes a
productive and practical enough decision
given as uncertainty about the future
despite his MidAmerican mannerisms and
his aw shucks smile Rob isn't normal non
by brain injury standards the severe
brain injury always result in some
degree of cognitive impairment the Rob
is lucid cogent and clever with no
discernible thought disruptions he also
has a precise recollection of what
occurred the day of his injury and he's
the only brain injured person I've met
who can provide most of the details
himself he went to work he punched in he
stalked and slept and he chatted with
another soccer about the dough I'd
cashier Cheryl who had just quit Rob
mentioned that he was going to meet her
at a party that night and perhaps he
would give him a call to join them and
his co-worker shook his head
the jocks always get the cute girls his
expression son Rob never did call his
co-worker though but he did get an early
start on the evening after he clocked
out Rob picked up a 12-pack and headed
to Indianola but it was a Thursday and
his friends weren't around or just not
in the mood so he drove back to Ankeny
and called Cheryl and she gave him
directions to the party Rob and his
coworkers measured time and typical
16-ounce fashion and eventually found
themselves dancing and drinking then
continuing the fun at a bar downtown
Cheryl talked about her plans to attend
Iowa State and become a nurse and Rob
told her that it must be nice to have a
dream or even a plan as the hours passed
they talked about how they eventually
wanted to leave Iowa and make it to a
bigger city where the options weren't so
limited and where they can find a little
space from their families they were both
ready to move out from under their
parents care and the more they talked
the more Rob felt sure it would soon be
time to leave at midnight only Rob and
Cheryl and their co-worker Bill were
left so they finished up their drinks
and climbed into Bill's Mustang
as soon as Rob sat down he found Sheryl
on his lap and she slammed the door shut
and threw an arm around Rob the Mustang
sped off into the night heading north
back to Ankeny november's in Iowa are
unkind the air was already I see the
majestic cornfields brown and tattered
and the streets were barren and slow it
was on a mean November night that Wayne
Matthews drunk and running late raced
his way home and his girlfriend's car he
had been drinking all summer and fall
and now he couldn't even afford to pay
her insurance as they had agreed mad
depressed an eager for bed Matthews tore
down the quiet streets up ahead he saw a
Mustang he decided was moving too slow
and passed it before he realized there
was a curb on the road his instincts and
fear kicked in a little too quickly and
he jolted the steering wheel to the
right and when he merged back into the
lane he clipped the front end of the
Mustang heard a terrible scratching
sound and then a loud bang the lights
disappeared instantly in the rearview
mirror and Matthews kept driving hoping
to god the car had just made a turn and
disappeared the Mustang did not turn
instead it rammed headlong into a
telephone pole effectively splitting the
car in half Rob was dead though with
certain and when the ambulance showed up
the emergency crew rushed to rob tried
to get his vitals and failing pronounced
him dead on the scene the emergency crew
bagged Rob while another technician
attended Cheryl bill emerged virtually
unscathed the crowd of firemen and
police buzzed around taking measurements
in collecting eyewitness accounts with
all the sirens finally silenced scene of
the crash eerily still as the flashing
lights illuminated small islands of
wreckage in that stillness the ambulance
driver turned his head toward Rob's body
bag and listened again
here here he heard gurgling noises and
within seconds he had the body bag
opened and was performing CPR on Rob we
got to get him on a flight yelled an EMT
grabbed the radio and called in a
helicopter the life flight team agreed
to take Rob abet among themselves that
he would not survive the four-minute
flight to the hospital the Rob did make
it and Cheryl did not Cheryl was a good
one
my friend would say her father still
calls Rob every year on Christmas just
to say hello so that's the the entry
point to the story of Rob rib and of
course some of you can guess a little
bit about how it ends because Kathy
herring is here and I'm very honored by
her presence the story like I said is
very special to me and I had the
opportunity to actually read it
in Kathy herrings home the same home in
which she heard from a policeman I know
about Rob's Rob's crash and it was very
sobering me for sobering for me to look
up and to actually see that door that
she had answered so many years ago and
gotten the news about her son's son's
brain injury that was how is Rob doing
Rob's a pretty fantastic guy he's
running a rehab out in Greeley Colorado
I'm happy to report it and he sounds a
pretty cheery every time when I speak
with him on the phone so well a well I
did talk with Kathy hearing in a few
minutes were you going to read another
selection yeah I would like to read
something else for you and this is a
this is from a chapter called the
hospital in the desert and it refers to
a military hospital in
Iraq that is 30 miles north of Baghdad
and it's located on a Air Force Base
they're called blood Air Force Base this
is the hospital in the desert above the
entrance to the air force theater
hospital at Balad air base hangs a
simple sign with red letters emergency
department for more than 800 people a
month a quarter of them Iraqis admission
into balada Hospital signals a turning
point in their lives a moment in time in
which their future takes a direction
they had never planned or wanted
if you're an American military or
contractor Balad is the gateway to an
elaborate frenzied ride through the most
aggressive medical system in the world
wounded Iraqis however go through the
experience on an altogether different
plane for them Balad hospital is the
seat where God wields his will among its
many honors Balad hospital has an unholy
distinction it is the brain injury
capital of the world the hospital at
Balad houses the only head neck surgical
team in Iraq so it sees more damaged
brains passed through its doors than any
other facility in the world after a few
months practice at Balad neurosurgeons
are emerging as the most experienced
neuro trauma specialists in history
should a brain injury befall you in
America you stand a 71 percent chance of
being alive one month after your ER
visit if a brain injury occurs anywhere
in Iraq and your medevacked to balad
your chances of survival skyrocket to 98
percent the highest rate of survival for
any trauma hospital in history what
takes the average emergency room several
hours to accomplish Balad orchestrates
in minutes record time from admin to
operating
room is 18 minutes I believe it's
actually 13 now
and that includes cat scan and lab work
20 years from now
American trauma care will be modeled
after blobs hospitals pioneering work it
is healthcare unencumbered by insurers
and accreditations the descent into blod
is a tangle of bureaucratic logistical
and psychological thorns although I had
already been vetted as a brain injury
case manager
it took me eight months of screenings
and cancellations in order to gain
clearance and another two days worth of
travel just to get on to the Air Force
Base in Ramstein Germany where most of
the flights into Iraq originate everyone
on the flight wears a long face that
only grows longer with the passing hours
and hardly anyone moves around the whole
of the c-17 until just before the
descent into Iraq when the license ID
the craft changed from pale green to
apocalypse red we grudgingly strap on
our bulletproof vests and Kevlar helmets
moments later the nose of the plane
lurches downward a combat landing
maneuver and we fall headlong into the
Iraqi nine descending into Balad I know
that I will be seeing brains I just
don't know whose imagine it will be a
soldier or maybe a marine I envisioned
the surgeon sawing away half the skull
and the bone flap lifting dramatically
as though it hinges like a jewelry box I
will see a brain it won't belong to
marine and it won't open that way at all
it will belong to seven-year-old Hashim
who should have been sleeping alongside
his little sister this night dreaming
while I am soaring miles above him his
brain will open like a hard-boiled egg
opens with a tap a crunch a starburst
crack
Bloods emergency room is striking for
what it lacks there isn't a waiting room
and there isn't a need not in the
hospital long before hazim is rushed in
on a rickshaw gurney swaths of white
gauze circle his head exposing only his
eyes mouth and nose his face is a dark
purple bruise mashed with dried blood
and dirt the seams eyes are closed and
his limbs flaccid and he doesn't react
when the trauma specialist pushes
needles into his arms he is immediately
surrounded by a quiet swarm of trauma
specialist Catalina who is the commander
of the hospital of the law it appears
beside me and within a whisper she
points out the various clinicians we
have a board-certified emergency room
physician doing triage on the patient
right now
she tells me I can see pharmacies here
there's a trauma physician tapping at
its belly there's another ER physician
inspecting his head we have another
trauma specialist unone and an oncology
specialist there a respiratory
technician an army medic a medical
technician starting lines for IVs you
can see three bags hanging they're going
to start giving blood the trauma
specialist more than a dozen of them
have done this hundreds of times already
reducing almost all need for verbal
communication they move wordlessly
nodding hands weaving up and down the
body while clinicians orbit the gurney
and one another it's a ballet of blood
pressure pumps and IV bags within six
minutes they have a scene fully assessed
x-rayed and on his way to the cat
scanner the on-site lab will process all
the blood work for fear of retribution
on hassium
and his surviving family members the
bombings details must remain a secret
the generalities involve a suicide
bomber and a mosque and in an explosion
that killed dozens and wounded
many times more the scene not old enough
to be in third grade is among the living
but barely his sister and some
classmates are among the dead I'm going
to take you in this moment into the
Iraqi ICU balata hospital the hospital
does treat a large number of Iraqis
there about 25% of their patients are
walking and I think what I'll do is I'll
begin with
describing a 2 year old patient on the
intensive care unit for him a dealer
isn't supposed to be here the Air Force
Theater Hospital at Balad airbase isn't
a pediatric hospital
although 10% of the patients are
children a track of 50 staples trails
the length of her torso fresh stitches
vestiges of an owner nerve repair
circled the circumference of her left
elbow both of her eyes were decimated in
the mortar attack Adila is 2 years old
and she has little bits of shrapnel
lodged in her brain extracting them
would only risk more damage she's
thrashing around and discomfort and it
brings a bittersweet smile to dr. Melton
slips that's a good sign he explains she
calms down when you pick her up and hold
her a deal his ability to respond to
pain puts her in a category above the
other brain injured Iraqis who live
beside her several of them occupying
ventilators no response to pain would
lower her Glasgow Coma Scale score which
could mean a quick move to palliative
care a final act of humanity before the
morgue
you have to keep in mind what is going
to happen with the patient once they
leave the hospital teff says if you go
to an Iraqi Hospital chances are high
that you're not going to have a
neurosurgeon there and the general
surgeon can probably clean things up but
they are not going to go in
side the head and do something they
don't feel comfortable doing what they
do is just take them home and pray and
if it is God's will the patient will do
well most of the time the patients die
when I look at a dealer I can hardly
take confusion in her face she is in a
great deal of pain she's crying and she
has no idea how her little life amounted
to this there was a bang and the light
of the world vanished she doesn't
recognize anyone's voice and English
words don't make sense the pain in her
head has to be an unquenchable fire and
the incisions and puncture wounds across
her torso and limbs sting every time she
moves what does she know of
nation-building and a religious law she
calms down when you hold her the dealers
parents do come around to see her Melvin
later explaining the problem is now that
she's considered damaged goods she is
blind she has heart problems and is
being fed through a tube at this point
in a rocking society a disabled girl is
a major liability and the girl will most
likely be discharged to medical City a
dealer or her parents may disappear in
the process if it is God's will she will
do well
I'm going to take you now into the
operating room where dr. Melton is about
to perform surgery on hasin it is in
this white sterilized shipping container
in the middle of a desert 6,000 miles
from my home did I see my first living
human brain a seems brain I've seen
brains pickled bloodless dried and
plastinated but never a glow for years
I've dodged other invitations to witness
neurosurgery I was content knowing the
brain only through action and aberration
now with a child as the secret bearer I
can face the matter directly I'm ready
to witness the brain and soul in a back
tent I put on the surgeons specimens the
scrub tops and bottoms a borrowed pair
of two big rubber clogs and I slip a
baby blue hair net over my head outside
the operating room to run my arms
underwater
lather them and the immense basins rinse
them once more and walk into the
sparkling white room the brightest in
all of Iraq
Melton the shaving has seams head
delicately and evenly as if he were a
barber he did the wet washcloth against
the scallops soaking up blood and mud
haseen stubble head reveals the damage
it has lacerations across the top and a
mangled flap of blue scalp tangles free
the top of his head must have bashed
against something perhaps he took a
flying brick to the skull at his seams
leg an orthopedic surgeon appraises the
jutting black tibia he glances at the
bone then at a tray of drill bits and
proceeds to set the leg in a sling I
take a seat on a barstool directly
behind his seams head and watch mill
Melton debride the wound you really got
to get things clean he says the bacteria
is in everything here including the dirt
if it gets ahold of you there's nothing
we can do it'll eat you up
melton uses a small set of pliers to pry
the bone fragments away from the seem
skull at moments he has to wrench the
cracked bone free a pile of small skull
chips collects near the discarded scalp
whatever you're doing it doesn't like it
so the anesthesiologist suddenly and I
look over at the monitor and notice the
seems heart rate plummeting down 30
beats per minute from a few minutes ago
give it to them little by little album
says without looking on the
anesthesiologist pushes on a syringe and
has seems heart pounds faster harder
when Melton when Melton's hands pull
away from his team skull I bow my head
down and I see circles of tissues within
tissues hair skin skull marrow dura
they're surrounded by brilliant white
bone is a glistening quarter size Ruby
seems brain slightly bruised with
droplets of blood dripping at the skulls
opening edge it is the shrine of the
seams being the temple where thoughts
take flight and dreams flash it is the
scene and not him impossible it pulsing
ever so faintly a seams brain is
expected to swell so Melton decides to
drill a pressure monitor and to his
forehead after the probe is set Melton
says have seemed scalp back on his head
the stitching pattern creates a thick
scar with the unmistakable shape of a
large letter W covering the crown of a
seams head
I got Paul Masons with us on this
edition of life and career light reading
selections from his new book called
headcases stories of brain injury and
it's aftermath published by for our
Straus and true I'm going to go to Kathy
herring in just a minute and get to give
the audience here a chance to talk with
you Michael Mason but just a follow up
on that last election then in rock have
you your thoughts on how things are are
doing now is there been any changes and
the way things are are treated there
well with regards to the Iraqi health
care situation it's I think degraded
even more since I've been there the time
of my writing of the book there were
10,000 physicians
left in Iraq this is down from 30,000
there are now reportedly less than 2,000
physicians working there so as you can
imagine just the shortages of personnel
alone is causing a major problem well
yeah there are most those are the
families you described in the book have
had extremely frustrating experiences
ones that you relate to talk to us about
wrong having to do with you know working
through the healthcare system but thanks
to the hard long and during work and
grassroots efforts if you will of many
of these families they've created
organizations and clinics and ways to
treat persons with traumatic brain
injury and as you mentioned earlier you
were talking about Kathy hearing in in
her son Rob would you go over maybe some
of the other some of the other people
who have been involved with it in this
area or or elsewhere some of the
families who have created had to go
ahead and create places - well one of
the things that I realize in traveling
around
and meeting survivors and their families
is just how critical a family member is
to a good outcome and you know Kathy
herring is a stellar example of this but
I write about another man Doug beard and
who gets herpes encephalitis and it
affects his brain to such a degree is to
be in cat incapacitating and he actually
suffers the delusion which he thinks
that he's dead his family went bankrupt
trying to find care for him and they
went through enormous difficulties and
not just financial but psychological as
well just sort of inhumane exasperation
and they ended up getting his treatment
fully funded on just by relentless @ad
vacations for him and and now they live
a relatively quiet stable peaceful life
the rehabilitation you know never ends
in his particular case but he does
continue to make gains and it's all
because he had this huge rally of
support around him so my heart always
goes out to people who don't have family
because it's so difficult
Kathy hearing is with us and earlier you
read the story of part of the story
about Rob rabe how are you doing Kathy
first of all great I'm doing great I'm
cancer-free so life is very good for me
and Rob is doing well as well yes he is
Rob's doing quite well in Greeley
Colorado and he has a wonderful life
wife Jeannie but you have went through a
horrific experience with helping your
son get better
can you give us the sense of what it
felt like to you and what you can
suggest
to other people who may be facing
similar circumstances well I think in
the beginning you don't know what to
think and you don't know what to ask but
for people today thank goodness there's
the Brain Injury Association of Iowa and
there's the Brain Injury Association of
America and those are wonderful
resources for families which back in the
1980
there wasn't anything for the families
at that time it was just getting started
up in Waterloo Iowa and when we were out
in Colorado at Craig Hospital dr. mark
Silas said to me Cathy you need to go
back to Iowa and you need to take your
energy and help get a support group
started there's great things going on
and he gave me a phone number of dr.
Walter Verdean and I came back to Iowa
but before I got Walter called one of
the families excuse me that we admit in
the acute care setting called me and
said we've been trying to locate people
that were in ICU the same time we were
in things and we want to get a group
together and that's what we did we met
in September of 1982 in December of 1982
we became the second support group in
the state of Iowa which was called the
central area support group and that
growth has over the past 20-some years
and now we have staff in Iowa that can
help families there's eight
hundred-number
there are the resources out there there
is more and there's a lot more that
needs to be done thank you I'm glad that
things are finally going well for for
your family
other if you have questions or comments
those in the studio audience them let me
know and Michael upon me feel be glad to
talk with you as well his new book is
called headcases in the book you
mentioned there are some circumstances
where it's really worthwhile to be
wearing a helmet now were you talking
about a bicycle helmet or a motorcycle
helmet or a football helmet well all of
the
depending on the the circumstance if
you're you know there are helmets for
all types of activities and I recommend
that you wear the appropriate helmet for
the appropriate activity yeah sure quick
one how restricted is the care allowed
to senior citizens on Medicare I'm
talking about what don't you financially
towards something that is often
discriminated against a that's an
excellent question and it I'm almost
embarrassed to tell you what the outlook
is like for the geriatric population
with brain injuries um that I know of
there are only about six beds in the
country that specialize in geriatric
care for brain injury survivors this is
a you know something that needs to be
rectified within the American healthcare
system
Medicare benefits rarely allow for
serious post acute rehabilitation
so most geriatric brain injury survivors
and open nursing homes and in my opinion
they're not getting the rehabilitation
that they need and it's it's a difficult
challenge to at that age well in almost
any age from what your books are and I
was struck to Michael Paul Masson about
how in many of these cases or many of
these stories that you relate some of
the patients did not immediately go to
for treatment after initially sustaining
an injury but the signs of traumatic
brain injury
I appeared gradually would you talk to
that and then we'll get back into those
sure well you know a brain injury can
often be a very tricky thing to the spot
right right away um you know the milder
brain injuries don't always result in a
loss of consciousness and so many times
the person you know feels like they just
got rattled or stunned a bit
they go back to work but current
thinking and theories suggest that the
injury actually begins to unfold over
time and so you know complications arise
as a result of that yeah can you give us
signs of traumatic brain injury or is
that just going to be going to be too
general well you know there are a number
of things that that should cause you to
you know seek medical care and this is
you know especially there's a loss of
consciousness you need to get checked
out if there's nausea that accompanies
the injury and this is at the on the
minor side of or milder side of severity
you know a disorientation any strange
qualities the that you suspect you
should always get an MRI or a cat scan
bones this is the question yeah kind of
going off of that same that same topic
or idea what would they do differently
if that was diagnosed earlier for like a
concussion or something as opposed to
later on in life that there had been
some type of actual brain injury
sustained is there any type of different
treatment that would have been taking
care of immediately yeah there is a
different care afforded when the injury
is spotted earlier you know depending on
the severity of injury you know the
physician may choose to you know take
greater strides so for example inhibits
swelling which is can be a huge
complication in brain injury however you
know that that doesn't mean that because
treatment at an early phase that you
can't benefit from a later phase there
is a myth going on in America that many
people feel that you have about a year
window before you can treat a brain
injury but research actually shows that
you can make gains many many years
post-injury
hi I'm just curious to know if any of
the proceeds from your book are going to
help patients with brain injuries or
their families a portion of the proceeds
will be donated to the Brain Injury
Association of America and they are the
foremost advocacy group for brain injury
survivors another question I have a 16
year old he's currently at the
University of Iowa Medical Center right
now he had brain surgery for the second
time in a year about two and two weeks
ago and I canvassed the country meeting
with consulting with the top
neurosurgeons on his fairly uncommon
condition and while it wasn't a brain
injury it was a malformation of the
brain what I found was that I had three
top neurosurgeons I mean top gun'
neurosurgeons in the country who came
back to me after looking at the exact
same evidence with three different plans
for to treat my son all surgically but
different different surgeries my
question is is that uncommon I mean I
think of the word practice practicing
medicine that really applies here
because I saw and heard a lot in my in
this Odyssey I've been on and I feel
quite a lot of experimentation I would
say and I'm just curious where are we on
that spectrum of you know like we think
that most doctors pop orthopedics
doctors said a bone probably the same
way but where are we on that spectrum
with neurosurgery is there's still a lot
of practice going on it varies greatly
by the individual shockingly enough to
give you a good example at Balad
hospital in Iraq there was a surgeon
that I wrote about in my discovery
article that his mentality was go big or
go home
so nearly every service member under his
knife got
you know got their krayem portion of the
cranium removed and you know went
through the whole a very serious major
neuro trauma operation however the neuro
surgeon that I met in Iraq actually had
the opposite philosophy he actually felt
that you know that that was the last
result resort going to someone's brain
in fact if there were tiny piece of the
shrapnel and there he he liked it to
leave them in because he felt that it
was safer leaving those bits in and
taking them out and causing a greater
injury to the brain and removing it so
there's a lot of variability depending
on the attitude and the you know the
perspective that the neurosurgeon brings
to the surgery you also relate other
instances and in these cases that you
have in the book about everything from
beds cold bedside manner to this
diagnosis elegiac spectrum and people
must go through in order to get
accurately diagnosed and treated it is
it's a testament once more to the
complexity of the brain Michael Paul
Masons with us head cases is his new
book and there's another question thank
you it's wonderful to have you here
tonight Michael my wife and I our oldest
son suffered a TBI injury in 1992 now
he's with us back there in the back
tonight so they learn a chance to speak
with him and I'm and he also cannot cry
so really so your your your reading was
very close to us
another thing about our son and I think
is very typical of brain injured people
is he can't find meaningful work we with
his disabilities we struggled for two
years fighting with Social Security to
get disability benefits for him finally
after two years after exhausting all of
our Appeals when we were
the last appeal is you go before an
administrative law judge at that point
they were well aware that once he
appeared before this judge he would get
it because of his situation so
miraculously we get a letter that now he
was awarded before just before we were
going to appear before the judge but
getting into that system they also place
restrictions on how much money you can
earn and if there are beyond that then
you lose those benefits and and now he
has gone on and gotten his bachelor's
degree from the University here now but
struggles to find work and and what I
see these people like our son and others
and and most brain-injured people that
we've encountered are living in a world
where they're locked into poverty with
no way out of it
and the one the one thing I think is a
failure at this point in time in the
system is there just doesn't seem to be
a good system for helping these people
get out of that cycle of poverty and
find jobs that will allow them to make a
meaningful life that is a good point and
I think that one of the good things to
come out from the Iraq war are actually
a conversations that are a little
glimpse of hope the the tide may be
changing and in terms of the health care
system the civilian healthcare system
we're hoping to parlay advocacy for the
veterans into advocacy for all Americans
with brain injury one of my hopes is
that the whole issue of vocational rehab
gets addressed as it stands right now
the American healthcare system in my
opinion is a fairly hostile place for
brain injury survivors because it is
it's legislation and its rules are all
built on this antiquated understanding
of brain injury as more of a mental
health condition it's not that at all
and so what happens is a lot of brain
injury survivors get put into the mental
health
services system which is you know it's
completely the wrong place I mean do we
send hard patients over to a dialysis
clinic we don't why would we send brain
injury survivors to a psychiatric you is
another question here for ya I just
wanted to say that I I think that a lot
of times that the system is afraid that
if there is more equity for people with
brain injuries that it's going to open a
floodgate because so many brain injuries
have gone undiagnosed well that is part
of the complication you know the average
civilian injury cost three to five
million dollars over the lifetime to
treat it's a very significant cost that
is usually absorbed by the family and
you can imagine what would happen if
suddenly all the brain injury survivors
all you know 1.6 million of them per
year were to start getting that kind of
funding would it would buckle the
current health care system so what I'm
advocating for is this major reform so
that you know those I don't think it has
to cost that much yeah and do you feel
hopeful than any I mean where do you see
this taking place and then he to do any
of the candidates for instance have good
thoughts on this so I you know Hillary
Clinton has done a tremendous amount of
work for veterans with brain injury and
Obama comes a close second in that
regard and so I applaud them for their
efforts I have been disappointed with
McCain because in in his supporting
statement of the wounded warriors Act he
actually viewed that view this act as a
which was intended for the care of
wounded veterans he actually made a
statement that said that he thought that
this justified
you know a long-term strategy for Iraq
essentially calling for more injuries to
occur it I didn't think it was the right
time to to use that as a political tool
spirituality and injury is something
that you wanted to briefly address here
Michael Thomas because it doesn't could
asked very often and so would you just
well yeah it's about that in the book I
write that brain injuries the most
spiritual injury because we walk around
with the sense that you know we are this
or that and what happens with brain
injuries that we see these things that
we take for granted all of a sudden get
abolished by a brain injury
Doug Gordon for example lost his sense
of life you know we don't typically see
that as a sense that we have but we all
feel alive his feeling of being alive
was taken away so you know the question
that becomes what is he if he doesn't
feel alive you know and so you know this
this journey of introspection I think
causes people to really question who
they are fundamentally are you writing
another book I'm in the process of
exploring a few different book ideas
with my editor he hid right he'd like me
to write a book specifically about the
Iraq war and you know the the injuries
resulting from that well thank you for
being on life in Prairie lights and
bringing on your book head cases stories
of brain injury and its aftermath to us
here last words about where people can
find information and well you know the
brain injury Association is the place to
go Brain Injury Association of America
that's BIA usa.org on the web and you
can call and request all sorts of
information from okay Michael Paul
Masson thank you so much for being here
I'm zero
Triana Chris Beckman engineer at the
program I'm Julie Englander please let's
thank Michael Paul Basin for this
edition of the closing
[Applause]